One of the most important things we want you to learn
from this course, is to develop the eye of a designer. So
you should be walking around the world, looking all the time.
Looking at things around you. Judging. Saying that's a really good example.
Or ooh, that's a bad example. But when you do this,
it's really good to document it Not only for your own benefit,
because you want to show them to other people. You might want
to show them to clients. You might want to give a talk.
And illustrate the points. So you have to have pictures.
And the pictures have to be effective. Show exactly the
point you're trying to make, and tell a story. So
it may take several pictures of the same object, to
tell the story. So, in this next assignment, we're going to
cover that. So let's start off though, with what it
takes to make a good picture. First of all the
camera. You know, doesn't do any good to have a great
camera if it isn't with you. So the
most important aspect about a camera is, have it
with you. So take a look at this one.
Cellphone camera. It's always with you, that'a a virtue.
The problem is, it's not really a good camera.
It can't be, it's just too small. So if
you want to take a picture, and the object is
really small. And you want to enlarge it. Nah,
cellphone camera isn't good enough. But, in an
emergency this is the best camera to use.
I use it all the time. The really best camera would be something like this. This
is a single lens reflex. It takes high
quality pictures, it's a very big detector. High
quality lens. But it's big, it's bulky. So
I myself, don't use it. I would love to.
But I just can't imagine carrying it with me all the time. So I
compromise. I carry a medium-size camera. Carefully
chosen, so it's of the highest quality. Yet small enough though, that it will
fit in my pocket. Or, it fits in a bag on my
belt. Has a good lens. Has a fairly large sensor.
So it takes high quality pictures that I can blow up. And all the
pictures, in the design of everyday thing
that I took, were taken, with this camera.
Second point. Take lots of pictures. Don't take one
picture. And don't sit there and just try to take
one or two. Professionals might take hundreds of pictures just
to get one. So take lots of pictures from different
angles, different zoom lenses. Closer, further away. And with
different lighting. Don't use flash. Flash wipes out all the
details. But make sure turn on all the lights. And
maybe use a piece of white paper as a reflector.
Do whatever you can do, to light it as well as you can. Naturally.